my name is Gaara kamsky I'm from New
York City I'm the current u.s. chess
champion I mean Carnac where I'm from
st. Louis Missouri and I'm the number
one ranked wrestler in the US I'm Levon
Aronian I'm from Armenia and I'm number
two ranked player in the world I'm my
name is Carson I'm from Norway and I'm
ranked as number one in the world you
know we're trying to promote our game so
I think everybody knows that it's a
first tournament of such kind in the
United States for a long time so I think
everybody is going to do their best
everybody is going to try to entertain
the public and play combative chest and
it's very prestigious and of course it's
the honor of the United States at stake
so we have to perform well so the
popularity of chad's in certain places
is it's very is very high but for me
it's all about America and for whatever
reason it doesn't seem like there's the
level of popularity at the moment and
I'm just hoping that whether it's me
whether it's camps you whether it's
players like Carlson or eroding that in
some way we can raise the profile I
think chess has the appeal of something
interesting something deep and that's
our condition I think that's going to
attract people of America it's really
quite nice to see that there are there
is an elite tournament
and again this tournament is the first
among many first that organized created
here in san luis de san luis is just
capital do yes it's only fitting that
you guys have you the best tournament
actually I can call myself a
representative of the capital of chess
here because we have so many clubs and
so many people but I feel tension
because I feel that that city of San
Luis is slowly trying to compete to this
I know that the US Championship has has
been here for for a few years I've been
following it online both both the games
and and documentary and I've heard only
only positive positive things about
about it and that's father reason why I
was eager to come here myself I think I
would have said I'm looking forward to
playing Carlson the most we played many
times before most people know I don't
have a good score against him so it's a
chance to kind of change things and I'm
you know I'm just gonna do my best I
played played kamsky I'm twice in the
world cup 2005 2007 he's extremely tough
fight till the end every time and and I
think I have some of the same cultus and
that's why our games are usually quite
interesting every player in the world
has unique style and the one is one of
the most original players you can ever
meet you know he's understanding of
chess his personality they're all very
unique I think my usual something
adventures on the borders of something
crazy
obviously I enter every tournament with
with the mindset that if everything goes
according to plan I should have a very
good chance of winning you know I'm
going to do really well that's what I
feel I don't know how well I just only
play for owner for glory and you know
for chess for the sake of chess it will
definitely not be easy and I look
forward to we all know shutter for many
years now played each other so many
games so it'll be intense and will be
interesting and hopefully the fans will
be well
you